الان الى ملف جديد هذه المره من مضيق
تايوان الذي كان مسرحا جديدا لتوتر امريكي
صيني فقد نقلت وكاله رويترز عن وزاره
الدفاع التايوانيه ان الطائره عسكريه
امريكيه حلقت فوق مضيق تايوان وقالت
الوكاله ان الطائرات الامريكيه وهي من
طراز بثمانيه
عبرت المضيق من الشمال الى الجنوب دون
اعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل
اما الجيش الصيني فقال انه راقب الطائره
الامريكيه عن كثب وهي تحلق فوق مضيق
تايوان صباح اليوم
اضافت جيشنا تحليق الطائره العسكريه
الامريكيه فوق مناطق تايوان يهدد الامن
والاستقرار في المضيق وشددت المؤسسه
العسكريه الصينيه رفضها هذا العمل
الامريكي
ولكن ما هي اهميه مضيق تايوان عقب الحرب
الاهليه الصينيه عام
1949 وانفصال تايوان عن الصين اصبح المضيق
الفاصل بينهما نقطه توتر جيوسياسيه منذ
ذلك الحين فهو يعد احد اهم الممرات
المائيه في العالم وايضا يعتبر قناه شحن
دوليه رئيسيه يبلغ عرض المضيق 130
كيلومترا في اضيق نقاطه
كذلك
المضيق يعتبر طريق طريق الرئيسيه للسفن
التي تحمل البضائع من اكبر الدول المصنعه
في اسيا مثل الصين واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه باتجاه الاسواق الغربيه وقد مر
عبر المضيق نحو نصف حاويات العالم اضافه
الى
88% من اكبر سفن الحاويات في العالم على
مدار السنوات وخصوصا عام 2022
ترى اذا اهميه هذا المضيق بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده ولحلفائها فهم يرون ان
الجزء الاكبر من المضيق يعد مياها دوليه
بينما ترى الصين ان المضيق جزء من منطقتها
الاقتصاديه وليس جزءا من المياه الدوليه
ولا هناك حدودا لنشاط السفن العسكريه
الاجنبيه فيها
ومعنا الان من بيج مدير مكتب الجزيره ناصر
عبد الحق ومن واشنطن مراسلنا ناصر الحسيني
وابدا معك ناصر الحسيني انت في واشنطن
التي كانت مشغوله بملاحقه مناطيد صينيه
واستاءت منها الان نحن بصدد استياء صيني
من الطائرات الامريكيه فوق تايوان اين
وصلت درجه الاستياء في واشنطن
درجه الاستياء في واشنطن عاليه هو تعتبر
واشنطن وعلى الاقل ومؤسساتها الامنيه تلك
المحاوله الصينيه للتجسس عبر البناطيد
وازمه المناطيد تعتبرها نوعا من التدخل
السافر
للغطاء الامنيه الامريكي وانها الى حد ما
اظهرت مدى ضعف الولايات المتحده في مواجهه
هذا النوع من التجسس الذي يقوم به يقوم به
الصينيون لنراقب لنلاحظ ان الولايات
المتحده برغم كثره تصريحات هنا وهناك ايضا
على الارض بدات ايضا ترد الى حد ما حسب ما
نفهم كما وواضح الان من هذه
المشاهد الاستخباراتيه وهذه المنافسه
الصينيه الامريكيه التي نشاهد ان الولايات
المتحده الان ايضا في الساعه القليله
الماضيه وكما جاء على لسان الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه والاستخبارات الصينيه
راقبت ايضا بدورها مرور تلك الطائره
الامريكيه من طراز بي اي ثمانيه اي على
طائرات تجسس كانت هي ايضا تمر فوق الاجواء
بين الصين ومضيق تايوان والكل رقبه ذلك
التحرك الامريكي وان كان هذا التحرك
الامريكي ان كان لهم معنى حقيقه فهو يجب
ربطه الان بذلك المعنى الاستراتيجي
لتايوان لحرب اوكرانيا لمنافسه المواجهه
الصينيه الامريكيه المباشره والواضحه
والعلنيه في مجال السياسه والاقتصاد
والطرق التجاريه والطرق البحريه وبالتالي
هذه التحركات وان كانت عسكريه
واستخباراتيه فهي ايضا تعبر عن مدى عمق
الخلافات الصينيه الامريكيه قبل ايام فقط
اعتقد ليس اكثر من 48 ساعه كان مدير
يتحدث في الولايات المتحده واعطى الى حد
كبير صوره لما هو قادم وقال
واشنطن مثلا الامريكيون يعتبرون الان ان
الصين تسعى بالفعل لاستعاده تايوان عسكريا
وسحدث ذلك في حدود
مثلا كشف ان الاجهزه الامريكيه تدرك وتعلم
ان الرئيس الصيني اعطى اوامر بان هناك
تعليمات للاستعداد العسكري لاستعاده في
حدود 2027 بعد عامين فقط وان الولايات
المتحده تعتقد الان ان الصين تشك في
قدراتها العسكري او بالتالي هذا النوع من
التصريحات الصينيه الامريكيه وكلها
تصريحات متبادله نوع من الحرب النفسيه بين
الطرفين تعطينا الى اي حاده الولايات
المتحده تريد ان تحتطر الصين وتحاول ان ان
تسيطر عليها استراتيجيا لان الامريكيين
يعتبرون اي نجاح للصينيين في المساله
التايوانيه ونوع من نجاح ايضا او يفتح
الباب واسعا على شراعه للحرب الاوكرانيه
للاستمرار في تلك الحرب واللي يريدون ان
تكون اوكرانيا او يريد الامريكيون بالاحرى
ان تكون اوكرانيا والرد الحالي العسكري
نوعا من الاجوبه الموجهه للصين اذا ما
فكرت في التوجه العسكريه نحو
وهنا اهم وابرز تخوف امريكي اشكرك ناصر
يعني في الواقع هذا اذا الموقف الامريكي
وحدت ودرجه الاستياء كما وصفها ناصر من
جانب واشنطن ماذا عن الجانب الصيني طبعا
تابعنا انتقادات وزاره الدفاع لوجود هذه
الطائره العسكريه الامريكيه ما هو الموقف
هل هناك تصريحات جديده ناصر عبد الحق في
بيجين تفضل
لحد هذه اللحظه ليله لا يوجد هناك تصريحات
تضاف الى تصريحات وزاره الدفاع او البيان
الصادر عن وزاره الدفاع الصينيه بان
الولايات المتحده بتصرفاتها هذه
بمنطقه مضيق تايوان تثير
القلاقل وتهدد السلام والاستقرار في
المنطقه حيث كما ذكرتم في المقدمه فان
الصين تعتبر منطقه مضيق تايوان هي منطقه
تابعه لها
وبينما تعتبرها الولايات المتحده منطقه
بحريه دوليه وترى بان جولاتها
الجويه والبحريه في تلك المنطقه تعتبر
اعتياديه لكن الصين ترفض ذلك جمله وتفصيلا
ما اريد الاشاره اليه ان منطقه مضيق
تايوان والتي هي بالقرب ايضا من منطقه بحر
جنوب الصين غدت خلال الفتره الاخيره منطقه
حساسه للغايه من الناحيه العسكريه سواء
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده او بالنسبه
للصين حيث خلال الفتره الاخيره كانت هناك
بعض الاحتكاكات في الجو بين الطائرات
الصينيه والطائرات الامريكيه هو كان اخرها
يوم الجمعه الماضي حيث اقتربت طائره
الصينيه من احد الطائرات الامريكيه التي
كانت تقوم بمهام استطلاع في منطقه بحر
جنوب الصين مع اعتبره
المراقبون العسكريون بانه خطر وربما في
المستقبل اذا استمر سيتسبب في عواقب وخيمه
لا يريد الجانبان لا الصيني ولا الامريكي
الدخول